each trading day at 11 a.m the chicago
mercantile exchange or cme hosts 10
minutes of electronic trading of these
blocks of wholesale american-made
cheddar cheese like some other food
products the last couple years of
cheddar trading have seen some wild
sessions
for example here is a drop that analysts
attribute to the first coronavirus
lockdowns when schools and restaurants
started closing and halting purchases
but during these swings on the cme the
price of cheese here at the supermarket
held pretty stable in fact if you chart
it out the price consumers pay for
cheese has stayed more steady than some
other common foods here's the change for
ground beef and eggs and apples
and here's cheese there has been some
inflation but the swings you see on the
cme are largely absent
with the price of many foods on the rise
right now we wanted to better understand
why even with the choppy wholesale
prices has the price of much of the
cheese we buy at the store stayed pretty
stable
the wild swings and wholesale cheese
prices play out on the cme's auction
platform traders buy and sell those
40-pound blocks and 500-pound barrels of
cheddar
the blocks are sliced and shredded and
sold to grocery stores restaurants and
others and the barrels are primarily
turned into processed cheese products
these are the only cheeses traded on
commodity markets and cheese sellers all
over the country watch the prices
especially of the blocks okay so i make
swiss cheese
i can't there's no spot market for swiss
cheese there's no futures market for
swiss cheese
but can i use the insight i got on
cheddar pricing
to say something about what swiss is
worth to better understand the wholesale
swings
we spoke to andrew novakovich an
agricultural economist who's been
studying these markets for over 40 years
if i think for example swiss should
always be worth more than cheddar at
least a little bit if the price of
cheddar goes up
well maybe the price of swiss that i
charge should go up so when the price of
cheddar swings like it did in 2020
so does the wholesale price of other
cheeses
again here's where bulk orders dried up
early last year and around here the
government started the farmers to family
food box program to help farmers weather
the storm it included a promise to buy a
hundred million dollars a month in dairy
products including cheese
all right thank you have a good day
there were several different types of
baskets that they authorized there was a
dairy basket and a milk basket and they
paid to acquire those products
put them in a paper bag or a cardboard
box
give them to local food distribution
centers we saw the price of cheese
absolutely explode
for a short period of time because there
was this requirement to get this huge
volume of cheese in a very narrow window
after a few months of shocks prices
returned to a bit lower than what they
were right before the pandemic as these
programs ran their course influencing
more sharp swings customers were picking
up vast quantities of cheese at stores
which brings us to the question at hand
why on average are these swings hard to
notice in the dairy aisle novakovich
attributes it in part to something
called price smoothing when prices are
increasing rapidly for some reason
grocery stores tend to say we don't want
to reflect all of that they anticipate
being able to recoup
that margin at some point when prices
recede so instead of
seeing quite the same roller coaster at
the retail level
generally consumers
see a much smoother
effect novakovich says customer
expectations can also influence pricing
strategies
take apples
because they're grown seasonally
customers may expect them to go up and
down throughout the year more than
something like cheese also cheese is
perishable customers may buy it more
frequently than other foods and would be
more likely to notice price changes
another incentive for grocers to keep
prices stable
while some in the cheese business have
had to weather big market swings
a smaller section of the industry has
managed to bypass much of the storm
aaron weiswall who owns an artisanal
creamery told us that while the cme was
swinging in 2020 his business was
thriving
2020 was one of our best years because
of farm markets and direct sales the
public did not want to go to retail
stores producing their own milk and
selling direct to consumers allows some
artisans to skip the wild wholesale
markets we are basically in farmstead
creamery which means we make most of our
own milk on site we age our cheeses in a
cave on site
and we original wisewell said that while
he's protected from some market
conditions 2021 has still presented
challenges 21 is rough because of labor
we're producing and selling everything
we make
but a few of us are working longer hours
to make the same stuff because we can't
find enough people to make it wisewell
said that while he's managed to hold
steady on prices so far
he's feeling this year's supply chain
pressures like much of the rest of the
economy the way we are doing it is
sometimes increasing the minimum
that the customer has to buy from us
changing delivery minimum increasing
delivery prices trying to hold that i
don't know how long we can hold them
if it continues the way it's continuing
it's gonna have
to get a boost
but uh we don't like to increase prices
uh and and uh we haven't probably
in cheese for almost five years
as the economy continues to see supply
and production challenges
the price of cheese on commodity markets
and in the store remains uncertain
you